[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
device for your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes i'm
joined by my co-host
dr greg sadler and our special guest
matt vanetta
and today we're talking about pain
mental health
and lived philosophy and dan mentioned
we have a special guest
he's really an extra special guest
because
you know matt banana i think people who
know anything about stoicism they've all
run across his good fortune podcast at
one time
or another he also has two new books out
that came out
i think was it was it this year or was
it late last year matt
late last year so i'm gonna plug those
right away
we have we have them both i i got them
because i i got uh
review copy so there's a beginner's
guide to stoicism
tools for emotional resilience and
positivity and then even
better well not better than the book
itself but it's better to always have
some sort of companion piece so there's
this five-minute stoicism journal
and the two you know they're they're
mutually supportive um
they're they're i reviewed them uh i
found they were
you know quite excellent and so i'm
really happy to have
uh matt on myself i know dan you've
you've
been you know reading listening for for
a long time as well right
yeah i was i've very strong memories
of riding my bike to my first startup
um it was five miles one way and i would
listen to it on my rides uh you know
sometimes in the middle of the night
like literally midnight and i'm
riding with a light on the front of my
bike and
matt vanetta in my ear talking about
stoicism well
i'm honored thank you and thank you both
for having me
oh yeah it's great so i mean we could
just
geek out about you know what it what it
took to start a podcast and a blog about
stoicism in in
you might call it the early years of the
modern stoic renaissance and probably
we'll get back to that but i know
you know we also wanted to talk about
some topics that uh stoic philosophy is
really helpful with like like
pain in particular um so why
why focus on that you know somebody
might be listening to this from the
outside oh
those stoics they're they're so uh
morbid
they you know they only want to focus on
the negative side of life and that's
clearly not the case so i'm gonna
turn it over to you matt and you can
well um although you know pain
uh is something that's come up uh
in in my life just by living a life
um i've been able to uh
more specifically think about stoicism
and pain in the past few years
because well man i want to say it was
two years ago now i'm horrible with
timelines but
i i started really
feeling bad joints hurting feet hurting
uh and such um
and uh i was also having uh skin issues
and all of that
and and eventually got so bad that uh i
was really um it was difficult for me to
get in and out of a
car um i had problem i live in a house
with stairs
and i was starting to be hard for me to
uh go upstairs where our bedrooms are
and such
and it ends up that uh i had psoriatic
psoriatic arthritis
along with other issues and that had
been going untreated because i
part of me was like i'm just getting
really old and i'm not
as fit as i was uh and then you know
eventually i hit the point where it was
like no this is beyond
beyond that and then i then i learned
what was going on
um and so so i've
you know just had through life um to
uh refocus uh stoicism in areas
that i've only had to like loosely touch
on
uh over time so uh and it's been
very helpful i was i was very glad that
i had a background
in in stoic practice prior
to these issues happening to me because
that's always
uh simpler than than learning it
fresh um yeah it's one of those things
where
you know you you can as people do on
these stoic forms right they say oh i'm
having this problem
what should i do and then everybody in
the world chimes in
and they bring up all these great
practices or passages and then
the person often is like oh this is this
is wonderful
now i can start doing something um
but it's it's so much more effective if
you've already laid the groundwork right
yeah yeah i mean sometimes i get worried
when
when people come in fresh not because i
don't think
that stoicism can be very helpful
because
because i believe that but because
so much of of what is best from stoicism
is from continual
practice and really wrestling with with
situations and a lot of the things
we throw at people or even just
sometimes basic ideas
are are are deep and sometimes hard
if you haven't had time to to wrestle
with them and and
and i always i'm like oh let's let's
find a way to
to bring this to people that that
doesn't uh frighten them off
but um but yeah uh so
and it it it helps me on the path
already
so i've had to start from scratch
absolutely that is
that is a good point though about the
not um scaring people off or maybe
overloading them
right um i mean dan runs a
weekly group where when the weather's
nice as it should be pretty soon
people walk around outside and there's
there's i think
at least my experience with it there
were quite a few people who were
curious and they they would come in and
they didn't really know much about
stoicism
and so you don't want to like you know
try to explain
the very nature of the indifference and
the relation of the the virtues to them
and
i mean that's that's a lot of great
stuff but it's kind of
tough to swallow all all at once um
so what do you think are the best
inns for people if they don't know much
about stoicism
you know some some ideas they can chew
on a bit
well i always try to make sure
that anything i'm focusing on
is is core issues of stoicism
um things like uh
what we sometimes term the dichotomy of
control
um uh you know
things like indifference or externals
like
does need to be addressed but i think
there's ways to go about it
that are uh um uh
you know ease people into that instead
of uh being
pretty callous yeah uh about it because
it sounds wrong we use this term
indifferent
to talk about things that are like
outside of
uh either outside of the moral sphere or
outside of my
you know ability influence morally but
we're not talking about indifference in
the sense
of of the of the emotional stance
of indifference and that's really easy
to to misunderstand
uh if it isn't clarified with people uh
and and can sound really harsh uh
depending on what they're addressing
at the time uh the end of course there
are like
basic stoic exercises and such that i
think can be
uh uh you know nice little entry points
as something to do
uh though and maybe when we talk about
the philosophy and such uh
uh i think that can be over emphasized
um
doing practices you mean the importance
of specific
practice practices right um
uh yeah you know practices i found that
for some of the people that i
work with some really love certain
practices and some
like despise sure um and
and so to a certain extent like we all
like that i'm talking with they agree on
the basic tenant systosis and what
they're like
yo that one that one just does not click
with me and so to a certain extent is
how one is from their experience in life
are oriented towards some of these
practices yeah and i've had
um you know i have a few key practices
that have been relatively consistent
uh as a go-to in my my personal life and
and some that have moved
sort of in and out depending on who i am
at the moment
right like so which i think is totally
fine and um
and you know the the bigger thing is
just
that the practice itself
when you're just talking about oh well
i don't want to say the the practice
isn't really
the philosophy right uh a practice can
be used
to to ingrain um the the values and
principles that come from
stoicism uh but sometimes they can be
used in
in in ways that have really little to do
with the actual uh expected or
outcomes of stoicism uh so you you got
to be careful how much you throw
throw a checklist stuff at people
because um
uh because not just about that right
it's i mean do you think there's a
danger with
certain of them in like making them too
central and then not using them in in
the right context because it's not
guided by the philosophy like you know
let's take the dichotomy of control you
some people they say oh well nothing's
in my control of these sort of things so
i'm just not going to care about them
whatsoever
all i can do is control my own you know
thoughts emotions reactions
so if my kid gets bullied um i don't
have to take care of that
that's you know as a matter of fact i'll
advise my kid to be a bit more stoic and
that'll help them out and when you see
people doing that you're like that's
that's a terrible idea that's
that's not stones that's all that's
almost like bordering on saul yeah i
guess yeah
i mean that's that sort of example is is
almost exactly what i'm i'm thinking of
is is that um
[Music]
there are ways to uh
use these what we you know stoic
exercises
that have nothing really to do with
stoicism or or you could flip it
on its head and and just talk about life
in general
right um like epictetus uh
in in his writings uh he he taught that
people could
could eat as a stoic could bathe
as a stoic and such but um
somebody you know going by somebody
having brunch
uh doesn't mean hey look there's some
stoics right because they're eating and
even could be done still
you know like like you need to there's a
there's a core
way of approaching such things that
actually makes it uh stoic or not
and even if the even if the practice
comes directly out of the writings
um it can be done improperly um
you know and i was just thinking
about how somebody could pick up the
wrong thing and be like well they're
they're ordering scrambled eggs so that
must mean
that that's what a stoic eats
so i guess it seems like you're you're
going to the topic of
lyft philosophy and the kind of the
difference between a life hack and a
philosophy's way of life
um do you seem to yeah
although now that now that we jump to
that
i'm like what what am i talking about um
well you know there are some you know
key principles
in stoicism i want to say this list is
what stoicism is because there's a lot
of different ways to approach
uh such a thing but um
well you know greg when you're talking
about a dichotomy of control and such
um stoicism is a very
communal uh and it's in its focus it
like stoicism assumes uh that humanity
is is social at its core as a as a key
principle
and um and whenever you read uh
even about yourself as an individual and
stoicism it's important to understand
that when they're talking about human
life they are very much talking about a
communal
person even though they're focusing on
you
and and therefore
it it doesn't make sense to read what
they're saying
as cutting off uh from from others
like i mean you can run into uh marcus
aurelius who
who who refers to to people who uh
who uh reject everything around them and
such as
as a cancer in the human body which is
pretty pretty uh
pretty huge and and
you know just there are there are core
aspects to the philosophy that that need
to
just be held in the mind as you use
the practices because then
you know you use that practice to either
bring you back to what you already know
as a principle of stoicism or to learn
how to
uh build that into your life and if
you're just
uh you know doing the thing for its own
for just for the sake of doing it i
think epictetus
uh talked about uh embracing statues
you know uh so um the the the cynics
uh were were were known as
diogenes would um would uh
just go out there and hug cold marble
statues
right uh as a as a form of showing that
he was indifferent
to to the cold and and the pain and all
of that
um which which can be used as a
as a philosophical practice like it was
a thing but epictetus specifically told
his
students don't do that uh because
he basically said you know i guarantee
you're gonna make that all about you
that is not you're just showing that
people look i can stand out here in the
cold
but what is that doing to change you
into a more virtuous and more you know
better expression of yourself right
and and yeah the rub here is that
like we're as humans fundamentally a
social creature
but one of the the largest sources of
stress that we have in our lives are
other humans
and so how do we live as a social
creature
when the thing that we we we desire
i guess one of the things that we have
like at least these core kind of like
biological desires
uh causes absolutely and we gotta watch
it because
uh like myself if if we're gonna use
like i'm not a i'm not a big binary
person but uh but if we're gonna use
like extrovert introvert
and things then i'm an introvert like
within within that
and um a lot of
people uh come to stoicism
and and feel it
in a like it hits their personality and
your personality is not the philosophy
right um like stoicism if it's
you know if there's any aspects of truth
to it should be
able to speak to to pretty much anyone
right
it claims it claims it could be used by
anyone
i'm not going to say everybody needs to
or not but but like it should be
accessible
and and that's and that's not to turn
everybody into one type of person
like stoicism that's not what it's about
and um
and it's really easy to use your your
personality as the bar for what
for what a good stoic is and then tell
other people they need to do that too
which is even worse
um yeah you gotta you gotta be careful
because
um you have my my enjoyment
of spending some time on my own
doesn't mean i'm being a great stoke
just by just
by virtue of doing that right or that
others must
you know it reminds me of there's this
passage in epictetus and i think it's in
book three where he's talking about
um you know people who are maybe stoic
sages
um any and he's talking about roles that
that they had
and he brings up socrates diogenes and
and xeno
and i actually saw this uh in somebody
else recently as well doing
doing something quite similar um and the
point was that each of them
did their things the way that they they
did it um
socrates went around and asked people a
lot of questions and
he wasn't doing the socratic method the
way we talk about it all the time if you
look at like xenophon or
or plato um but he did actually ask a
lot of questions diogenes didn't ask
people questions he went around and in
addition to
you know hugging statues he got in
people's faces and insulted them and was
kind of
kind of a jerk and
xeno trying to just like get a shock to
your system what's wrong with that
and that's that's part of the point that
epictetus is trying to make xeno went
around and taught
and made distinctions and and you know
all of those sorts of things
and each one of those is a legitimate
way of
doing stoicism you know or if we want to
count cynicism the way that epictetus
seems to be
willing to you know roll it in there
each of those is a legitimate way of
doing things and then if we think about
our own
lives i mean i'm not i'm not going to
try to be a socrates or a zeno or
anything like that but i can
you know i can think about how i treat
my students
especially in this time when a lot of
them are really struggling
or um you know fulfilling this this
obligation to
keep uh producing radio shows you know
for for milwaukee and for and beyond or
any other thing right and and what i'm
doing
is probably gonna have some similarity
to what the two of you are doing
and so many other people are doing but
it's gonna be it's gonna be stylized
it's gonna be
rooted in the context of my life right
and same thing with with
both of you and anybody else i think
who's listening to this
i wanted to bring up the the thought
that matt
brought up earlier about how kind of you
could look at
socialism as really fundamentally
egalitarian that it
is useful for that person
as lowly as you know a roman slave up to
the emperor the
arguably the most powerful individual in
the world and how
this had this same philosophy
has the ability to speak to and help
both of these groups of people
regardless of their like material
decisions
so you were talking about um some of
these uh
exercises and challenges and how uh
you would really like to uh like
when you were talking about socialism
see it as a live philosophy
and not to just be these life hacks and
as
wondering what your thoughts on do you
think this is encompassed by the term
like practice or sorry praxis which is
theory put to practice and so instead of
just like these little pithy practices
that you can take or leave
and without even talking about the
theory
and and you know as you were
uh you made note of of on you know in
discourses 1 4 talking about chrysippus
like oh that guy knows christipus but
that doesn't mean
anything until he actually does
something with that but
these these two hand-in-hand together
are the things that actually
produce these outcomes that you would
you are
hoping to get when you're working
through these processes
absolutely like um i mean there is
obviously some aspect of study
necessary in the sense that um like to
know what we're even talking about
mainly because most of us don't get to
actually
meet a stoic teacher in
in a sense and have them tell you right
you know so you got to do the work
but then you got to do the work right
you have to actually apply it and these
exercises
can be great for for doing that right
like that there's a
there there are exercises i do on a on a
daily basis
and such so i don't have anything
against uh having a practice
but the key is the practice is actually
putting into
into play um these these
these thoughts that you to wrestle with
them to put them into your daily life
and see them change you i i ideally
right
you know and um and you know all the
all the uh the stoic teachers that we
still have some access to epitidus
um sonia's rufus and such we're very
clear that like
practice is a thing and that it's deeply
important
but you have to you gotta
you gotta watch it right it's not about
the specific exercise it's about what
you're learning
and it's not about the book learning
if it's not actually changing who you
are
um you know as you as you said that uh
in um discourses one four uh
on progress um epictetus
uh is is sort of berating a couple
students
uh in this in this talk about how um
one of them was really impressed that a
newer student
was was really good at understanding a
uh um chrissy chris uh
who's like uh known for being uh not
only a very
smart very capable philosopher but also
a very
uh very intense and
and very uh detail-oriented in his
writing and such
uh like it took a lot to wrap your head
around those writings
um and but epictetus
sort of made fun of them uh because
uh he said this older student uh
had his head on wrong like that he was
doing he was approaching this wrong
he said he's like because this this this
kid
is just learning for the sake
of of being you know he's he's using
stos
stoke jeopardy right he he wants to beat
so in jeopardy
uh he was like is this you know is this
making you better with a desire an
aversion is this uh helping you create
but take better actions
are you are you learning about uh how to
give or how to withhold a cent
right like because if that is happening
awesome right
but if you are you know if but if it's
not you're wasting your time
right uh yeah otherwise you're just a
you know a voice recorder hey look i can
play this back
yeah absolutely well or or a show-off
you know somebody who i mean i've had
students like that and i've been that
student at some times where you bring up
stuff to just show how much you've
you've been able to master and then you
know i i'm fortunate that i never
actually had anyone quite as
uh rough as epictetus to say so
what do you do with any of that you know
show me show me what you can do but
but you know i remember getting called
on that sort of thing and having to
learn that lesson
that uh and it wasn't with you know
stoicism it was more like you know
contemporary continental theory
uh but then you know you get challenged
well what does this actually mean what
do you
how do you translate this into to action
and
and then it you know you could have one
of two reactions one would be oh well
you know
i don't like this i'm going to withdraw
from this and and go
and find some people who will think that
i'm really cool because i can parrot
this stuff
or you can like you know take the bump
to the nose and say oh i've got to
change something here and then you can
have a nice learning
uh painful learning period
so matt here's a softball do you
consider your books
to be a nice one-two punch of theory and
practice your most recent two i hope so
i hope so um yeah thank you
greg for a a kind review um
yeah it was it was interesting uh
writing though so they are definitely
laid out in a way
where like every single section has
a variety of actual practices or active
things that you can do and that's
intentional
right because uh because i'm not against
it i think people do need
you know it gives you a hook right it
gives you something to actually latch on
to
and actually try to use the philosophy
but but i do um
you know the the part that's more
important to me uh
is the the
principles the the values that come with
stoicism as opposed to specifically the
little
the little hooks so i'm going to ask a a
non-softball
follow-up question about that and it has
to do with the kind of book that you
wrote where i mean it is a beginner's
guide right
so as you're saying every single part of
it you know
and there's it's very short sections
describing practices or ideas or
giving suggestions i would think that a
book like that
could have two different kinds of
authors one would be somebody who
doesn't actually
know that much about the topic and then
they just like look around okay what are
the most popular
things that people reference on blogs or
you know
whatever and then they put them together
and they're like okay now i've got it
done
and the challenge for them is like
there's two challenges one is actually
finding enough material
and then the second challenge is having
it all cohere
with an author like you who's you know
been practicing
thinking these things through has read
the original text over and over again
i would think that it would be almost
the opposite where
writing a book like this this this short
with such short sections would be tough
in part because you like
i want to add more i want to say they
want me to say something
in you know 200 words wow it really
takes about 600 to unpack this properly
right so it was was that kind of a
challenge for you or not
i had to continuously remind myself
this is a beginner's guide and
if i and if the person
reads it and finds it all useful um
the point is for them to move beyond and
and find other things and that's why
there's a little bit of resources listed
and so on and and so forth but yeah that
i mean it was an interesting challenge
in that i would have a thought and be
like
okay that's that's a book that's
that's its own book that is not that is
a section uh
and uh and so i would be like okay what
what aspect of this would i want
people to be able to to to latch on to
and like
pick up and then if they find that good
they can go and explore on their own
right you know so
so yeah it was it was difficult and the
whole the whole
writing process there was was quite a
thing it was a unique group to work with
uh
that that that press so uh
so yeah it was it was different but
um but i enjoyed it i learned a lot
about
the process and uh
and uh my own
thoughts about about teaching it by
doing it so
yeah great so i
want to come back really quick to uh
on progress discourses 1-4
and and they talk a lot about
um what what are the the things that
you're actually getting here and so
he's like don't don't be like the sheep
regurgitating its crud
because that doesn't actually show you
what uh the outcome is you
you look for the outcome would to be
like a nice full
fleece on that sheep and um or
for like a weightlifter or a
weightlifter doesn't go like hey look
look at my my nice weight set over there
that doesn't actually show you the
the proof in the pudding is the the
actual
the muscles on the weight lifter and uh
so uh in on progress is like
what does this achieve what does this
practice met with
theory actually produce and at least in
the the stoic work of this
it's you know peace of mind or
equanimity is one of the
the outcomes that you can see within
this and
i guess i want to know if you had any
thoughts on that
yeah um
like i would say if there's anything
that
that um really
drives me when i'm trying to communicate
stoicism
uh it really is uh
a focus on what what what does it mean
to make progress in
in in this way right um
and uh
and it gets interesting because you know
there's a lot of ways to think about
flourishing about um about
uh you know happiness and such you know
things that people
uh everybody comes to it with a
different idea of their
what what might be being at peace right
but
for me it's a very active thing right
like um
you can't look at the stoic
good life isn't a
destination and traditional sense in
that you know
if if you want a peaceful i
feel calm in my in my walled garden you
go to
the epicureans right like so like for
for the stoics
it's about um a good flow of life right
is one of the terms that get used and
that means movement
right um epithelius brings up things
like choruses where people
uh it might be in one four actually
where
oh no no no no it's enough fragment but
anyway
so uh but he uh he talks about how like
if somebody was
doing a good job in a chorus they're not
only singing their best
but they're hearing everything around
them and they are
adjusting themselves and responding to
the chorus
so that they are all in harmony right
and um
and like that really it's you know
virtue
uh which is a term that comes up in
stoicism a lot
is about this skill of of approaching
life
um in a way that that allows you to
really
flow with that life and and um and
that's
that's central right i really feel that
like where
where our talk and modern stoicism can
get lost is if we
if we get into either these
the little just the nitpicky weeds right
like if
like uh like i i find all aspects of
uh like stoicism even things that i
don't
um fully agree with from the ancients uh
to be interesting like it's like it
sparks my interest like i like learning
uh about such things like i i am not um
uh a theist so uh
so the um uh epictetus for instance so i
and
enjoy a lot but like his exact approach
to
the universe's god doesn't fully
resonate with me although there's
there's a fair amount in what he's
talking about that i can also
uh gain from just from a different point
of view
but but i find that stuff interesting
but people will like
like try to figure out like like you can
do the math
and like suddenly crack stoicism on
things like the physics and the
logic and all that and it's like well is
that it
by by pursuing that is it
is it changing how you are in this world
like are you
are you being a better you through this
right
so if you if you're if that is happening
awesome
right like and i think people can find
that from all over depending on who they
are but
it's really easy to get like hung up in
a corner and just sort of spinning
when when like you're not changing
anything
internal here here and such
i just point to my head in my heart
sorry they're
radio people coming back to
um criteria for whether you're making
progress so
you know equanimity uh you know being
able to respond to
the challenges of of life but how much
of it would also
going back to this social nature of the
human being as stoicism conceives of it
could you say like another
another criterion for making progress is
you're not such a big jerk to everybody
and you know you can get along with a
wider range of people
or you know take interest in what what
they're saying i mean could there be a
bunch of different criteria that are
more other
centered that way or absolutely i mean
i think um
i think like if you're really taking in
what the stokes are talking about
then um the people
not just in your life but just
people um are going to become
more important on on their own
like they will they will radiate their
own importance by being people
because because they have equal value uh
to you
and not just not just equal value but
also are
are part of one thing like the stoic
sort of conceptualized the humanity
as a as a body in itself right that
like that we are all uh one in many ways
uh aurelius talked about how we were the
uh
the upper and the lower teeth right
coming together videos
things like that like really it's
intimate
right and and that doesn't mean
i mean this is a this is a hard world
where
where there are very legitimate reasons
to
to stand against people uh sometimes
right to not
not exactly align with them and such but
that doesn't neces
that doesn't change their value right
like so it's not
like even even in conflict the
the value of that other person remains
in stoicism that like you don't just
write them off you might have to be
really
confrontational or something but like
you it remains true
that they are valuable and if and if you
happen to be right and they are not
right
they're misguided but that doesn't make
them
lesser and and that should really
balance how you approach
uh things in life it it it's because it
changes the math
uh compared to the way that people
sometimes uh
approach conflict yeah or
or sharing resources or um
you know all sorts of other things that
have to do with justice right
right so if we're not if we're teeth and
we're supposed to be working like the
upper and lower hand
and we're not aligned the stoicism
braces
oh well i mean maybe maybe the practices
are like the braces right
they bring things into alignment right
yeah uh sure i could see that showing up
i was really interested to um hear your
thoughts on this this note that you have
here on uh roadhouse
oh yes so this goes back to pain um
for those of you who are not familiar
there was a
movie called road house patrick swayze
uh starred in it and at one point his
character says
the line pain don't hurt pain don't hurt
um and then a fun part of the scene he
says that to a doctor
tells that doctor that he doesn't need
any uh
any um medication before getting
stitches and then uh
gives a really hard wince when they
start doing the
start doing the thing so uh so
you know pain don't hurt but uh but i i
really like that
um quote when it comes to pain
management and i actually
use that quote talking about pain well
before i had personal
issues with with chronic pain and that's
because um
so so for me in pain management like
there's a lot that people should be
doing like actually
seeking out professional help and such
if you're dealing with chronic pain
not just for the physical aspects of it
but also perhaps for the mental
depending on how it's going for you but
but from stoicism what i get
is uh stoicism has this
a whole psychology uh to it and one of
one of the things is this idea of um
what was uh well seneca uh poetically
called the first movements of the soul
um which is that initial that initial
impression
of of just what what happens to you
right
so it's it's it's seeing something it's
hearing something
or it's feeling something like my hands
right now are doing okay my medications
are working so i
i can i can grip but on certain days i
can
i can barely like my hands a claw i
could hold a grapefruit
but i can't go make my fingers move past
that right
and and that pain uh is a first movement
in the sense that like it's a very
it's below rationality it's how your
body instantaneously responds
to its environment right and uh
so then that line says pain don't hurt
and if you know if i want to turn that
into a stoic line then the hurt
is as what we would refer to as a scent
um or at least it's within that realm uh
you have an initial impression
and then your mind who you are does
something with that and
invests meaning into that initial
impression
and where pain
i mean pain pain is pain right like it
like um
like i can't stop the fact that my hands
can really hurt
my feet can hurt and and such um
but i can address how
i mentally respond to that
right and a lot of pain
is is layered on
by our our response to the pain versus
the pain itself
so um it's really easy
to get that feeling that this will never
end
right and with chronic pain it in some
ways it might not right so like it's
hard but it
but it's still like pain is an
interesting thing and and you can learn
that the sensation changes over time and
such even if it never fully goes away
and then um you can think about your
loss of capacity
right uh the first time the first time
that my uh
my arthritis got so bad that it was like
it became impossible for me to
like open a basic lid off of something
like it really hit me hard emotionally
like there's just a moment
that i can think of in particular in the
kitchen just over
away from my the room i'm in right now
where like
just that it felt like a big loss and
and i didn't want to ask for help right
and there's things like that
that turn pain into something much worse
than than a simple physical response
right and
and so one of the things that stoicism
works on
is not instantly investing
a storyline into that initial impression
right it's finding a new way to
to to approach that over time and that
has been
extremely helpful for me or for pain
management
so part of the things that get connected
in with it are emotions like
anger you know i shouldn't be feeling
this or um
fear you know is this going to go on
forever or people are going to see me as
less
or maybe shame um and i know
you know stoicism does have a whole
theory of emotions did you did you
find um thinking through that stuff
helpful in dealing with
with pain to to have pain just be pain
and not all this other stuff that's all
yeah what would we say snowballing out
of it no absolutely right
i mean that's something like the
emotional stuff
helped bring me to to finding stosom
even interesting
and like it's it's always been there
right so i've always had
that practice right is is like what you
know what it what does anger mean to me
what does uh envy mean
and all of that and and it's all it's
all part of this
a very similar approach right like what
what is
you know just because i experience this
thing
what what is the actual meaning of it
what do
and i can make a decision based on that
so yeah
a lot of that was helpful to already
have
now something i find interesting
and just this is just life right is um
and maybe maybe it's who i am as a
person and such but i think we we talk
about
lessons as as big universals
and like like if you if you deal with
anger in this one area
yeah then you've dealt with anger but i
i find that life is much too
compartmentalized
right you know like that like like you
can really make big strides in a
particular area of your life and then
something new
and novel happens and suddenly you're
nearly back to square one right because
you're like
you're like wow i did not know i was
going to have that that particular
reaction right and so um but
then again having real thought out and
and learned practice in in
one area does tend to
give me the footing okay yeah to like
and start adjusting it but i still have
to do real work that's
that that's the main thing that's
another thing i find yeah i mean
i'm sorry it's sort of like saying you
know i can play this
this i used to play a lot of different
instruments and more
more putter than play you know so like
when i was a kid i played the clarinet
and you know that meant you could pick
up a saxophone and probably figure
out how to how to finger the stuff and
make the notes
and then you know you could also like
get a flute and now you've got a whole
different embouchure that you have to do
but you know the the keys once you get
the theory of it
it's all kind of similar but it doesn't
mean that you can
easily then pick up a violin right or a
guitar
or anything like that and even even
within the range of
of you know a very narrow range of wind
instruments
if you're good at one that doesn't mean
that you're automatically good at the
other but there's this notion of
transfer
i think that's a good criterion for
whether you're making progress
as well it should transfer you know if
you manage to figure out one
relationship and you're doing so with
stoicism or any other intentional way of
living
then it should you know be usable with
workplace relationships or
i don't know not getting ticked off with
your neighbor
yeah sure i mean whatever whatever range
we have right
i mean there's there should be some
things like if you're if you're figuring
out your romantic relationship obviously
you shouldn't you know cut and paste
that onto
i don't know the guy you sit next to at
the bus yeah
but but as you said there is transfer
yeah i want to
really quickly go back to uh pain more
directly
and you know one of my favorite quotes
is you know
uh is whenever you are paying by an
external thing is not the thing that
disturbs you but your own judgments
about it
and it is in your power to wipe out this
judgment now and so this comes back to
as matt was talking about the way that
impressions arise and if we're going to
give a scent to it or not and in that
space between them we have
that choice that rational choice
and how
like i've uh experimented
and done some decent amount of like
mindfulness meditation and i've
i've done this with pain and other like
sensories and i see
like these pains like they just happen
and so they are
like these impressions or fantasia um
and uh to sit with a pain
or some other pressure that is a
sensation and not
see it as the pain or the um
as you know patrick swayze is pain don't
hurt
um it's just a signal but our judgment
is that it does hurt and that we want to
be averse to it
and you know it's not going to make the
pain go away but it does put
the pain into a a new category and if
you look at
pay your qua signal or in the the
i know the character of or the the role
of a signal instead of a the role of
hurt and something i want to be averse
to you can you can
start to at least um look at this as
instead of this uh unadulterated
bad i guess that's completely
adulterated
that you can see it as it's just a
signal
um and it's not going to solve all your
problems and
like this is probably going to be a nice
segue into our next thing with mental
health
that like still go to a doctor it's
probably not good if you have some like
underlying condition that's causing all
this and if you have some
way to be able to resolve that but it
doesn't mean that is
the only option and uh
for us to try to mitigate yeah
absolutely
um well
pain pain lets us wrestle
with um so when we talk about
dichotomy of control and and things that
are
considered externals one that's that's
really interesting
uh that i i even don't always see
stokes thinking about is that epictetus
uh
very specifically lists the body as
as part of that right that your own body
is an external in the sense
of it is a thing that is in in some ways
out of your control
and when you are very healthy and doing
well it can be hard
to understand what he's talking about
sometimes right and even even he and
he talks about things like you know
being thrown into chains and such i mean
that the man had been a slave
and such so like uh so he had to use
that that
sort of outside force there but like
when you deal with
pain and you don't know during your day
when a part of your entire body will not
function
properly for you and such it really
brings home
like where where does control really lie
and it's not in that it's not in the in
the body
um now now i i do want to say though
um and i think it's important for people
to
like hmm how to say this uh
i think at the same time that that it's
very helpful to get that
that lesson that that the body is
outside of your control which can allow
us to release
a certain amount of of struggle over
over pain and treat it more like a
sensation
uh there is a flip side to that where i
do think it's also can be important
to understand that like pain of the type
that i'm talking about
is also part of our body right like that
that
it's part of our our processes because
because i
there is a a lot of people take pain and
they start
thinking of it as this like outside
thing like an invader
on the body and i think that also
creates certain types of resistance
uh that that need to be dealt with right
that like
feeling like this this enemy is
attacking my body
is is creates some stresses
um that that that don't necessarily need
to be there and i think
with these stoic practices you can you
know learn that
you know this pain is separate from like
my core self and such
but it is also in a sense a natural
process of attacking
to me and and therefore like i don't
need to treat it
as as removed as
as i might want to because if you're if
you're trying to really box it up
you're going to lose because because
it's going to keep showing up
all right so i don't i wish i could get
more specific on that but i i don't know
how to say it
so speaking of the the body being
outside of our control
uh how about the brain and look at
what's
maybe communicating or the more mental
health yeah um
i came i became interested in stoicism
for a couple of reasons
and one was its connection to cognitive
behavioral therapy
um basically because uh
i had gone through cbt therapy
uh over the years and when i first
started hearing some
some stoic lessons i noticed the overlap
right and i was like what you know and i
thought it was interesting that it had
been around for a long time
uh so then i started looking it was
actually um an interview with uh
bill irvine um who uh yeah when he was
first promoting
yeah yeah um i suddenly can't recall can
you
can either you recall his his first big
stoic book it's pro
yeah suddenly having a fraud sorry about
that i suddenly
can't recall the william irvine is the
writer um
yeah it had to do with um um stomach joy
yeah right
uh so this is not that's right
donald robertson the art of perhaps joy
or something like
the art of stoke joy or something um
yeah but he had been giving an
interview on like a press tour for that
and i heard that
and i heard some overlap i don't think
he brought up cbt uh but uh but i was
like well
that's interesting and uh and so i i
started looking into it
and um yeah like i struggled much longer
than with
chronic pain i i've struggled through
like my entirety of
uh late teens to now with
uh anxiety and depression so um
[Music]
so the i'd so stoicism a panacea for all
mental health hills
um it is not uh stoicism
i would say that if we could truly
take in its its message and enact it
um can really help um
people find like like like bill's book
with a joy
uh and um contentedness
and such not not 24 7 uh you know joy is
not one
was one of those things that comes in
and out uh but you can create a space
for it
um through stoic practice but
yeah it really disturbs me when people
show up
and it becomes obvious that they're
trying to avoid therapy
by showing up on a facebook page or
something
um and that is something that i very
quickly like
you know as a as an author and back with
the podcast and everything i get emails
from time to time of people asking for
advice
and i'm willing to give some level of
advice but i always start off with
you know larger problems you know like
there is an entire profession and a
capable one if you find the right people
um that that understands you know
these underlying issues in a way that
like piecemeal coming to stockism
is not going to easily give you and it's
not that
stoicism can't be there in in that way
it's that it well one
we tend to become dystocism on our own
right and when you're approaching
something on your own
uh it's really hard to
see your your own struggles clearly
right it's difficult
um you know it if the problem is
thinking wrong about something
it's hard to fix that without being
confronted
uh in a way right and there's also
things that just require
uh might require you know medication
and and such when i first and this is
before
it came to stoicism but when when i
first was
when i first went for for help i had
just
come out of the military i'd been
dealing with years and years of
undiagnosed depression and anxiety
and i was a mess and i did seek help
and the first thing was like uh
cognitive behavioral therapy
but it didn't hit and uh and a big part
of it was because i was
deeply messed up like there were a lot
of issues
um and and i couldn't wrap my head
around
what they were doing even when i tried
and
a few months later i was uh given
medication
and uh and medication didn't change my
way of thinking or anything
but it it stopped some real noise
and it gave me a space and suddenly i
was able to like
go oh that's what that guy was talking
about yeah and such and then things
started to really click
and i was i was doing that for years and
later with stoicism and learning that
practice but still requiring things like
medication because of
my particular problems um and i've
had huge help but i needed professionals
so for a little bit of an analogy here
that i like is that
if one wants to be an excellent at the
art of driving a car a functioning car
is
a prerequisite and a lot of times you
can't be your own mechanic
but i'd like to get to our practice here
before we run out of time
we're gonna have to go through this
pretty quick then too yeah
so uh the practice is a festival and
you uh bring up a as
potentially from discourses 112. it
simply involves
reframing any situation involving people
as a festival that you choose to
participate in any quick thoughts
yeah um we've all been in a place
uh that we wanted to be in and then the
noise and the revelry
was okay right uh if you go to a
festival and you want to be there
then it's fun when people are being
rowdy and so on and so forth and if you
can take that mindset
to just existing around other people uh
even when they're being
annoying and such if you're being in a
big crowd that's what that's what
updates said right if you're in a crowd
call it a festival and i really think
it's a very quick thing but my wife and
i actually will literally just turn to
each other sometimes and be like
festival and it really it works as a
reset
it works as a quick reset that's that's
really great so
we're we're just about out of time we're
going to give you
our final thoughts uh so
take it away so this is from marcus
aurelius
i got the name for my podcast from this
line
which is bad fortune
born nobly is good
[Music]
you